what's happening there reject nation
greg and john here today we're gonna
watch the official trailer for the boys
season three which we will be covering
on this channel a lot coming out in june
so we're gonna need some additional help
with editors so with that in mind enjoy
today's video sponsor thank you to
athletic greens for partnering up with
us this month well the schedule is wild
as ours it's tough to stay on top of
proper diet and nutrition luckily
athletic greens eg1 formula makes your
daily nutrition simple delicious
inconvenient get bigger just one scoop
contains 75 high quality vitamins
minerals probiotics and a whole bunch
more which supports gut health nervous
and immune systems energy focus plus on
a serious note ag-1 is lifestyle
friendly i'm actually allergic to dairy
so any shake i ever have has to be
dairy-free so whether you eat keto paleo
vegan dairy-free or gluten-free it's a
good fit plus it's completely natural no
harmful chemicals or gmos and for my
sake it helps improve my sleep quality
and mental clarity which is always a
boost it helps improve my gut health i
like to poop and i like saving money and
what's great about athletic greens is
your subscription only costs about three
dollars a day that's double what i paid
john and it comes with a year supply of
vitamin d and all that is way cheaper
than trying to get all these supplements
individually so head on over to
athleticgreens.com rejects to start your
ag-1 lifestyle today
so let me say it again cam i may be a
superhero but i'm also just a man who
fell in love with the wrong woman he's
the man who fell for the wrong woman uh
for the wrong woman
she was a great nazi
i am very excited for everyone to meet
the real men
there's something wrong
[Music]
we've been on the straight and narrow
all year
i'm killing soups no drinking
even follow hugh campbell's orders
without strangling him
no you're just being crazy or maybe
you're not such an [ __ ]
people are super dumbs just to be with
this family
but real power isn't this
it's the ability to bend the girl to
your will
oh
yeah
oh no
oh god
we can fight about the right way but we
can't it's all rigged we have to do it
your way
oh
we're all we've got
it's up to us
i think i have something
what you got
[ __ ] brains out
doing falcon winter soldier problems
yeah for 24 hours
you're gonna need it nice yeah here we
go boys
go point what we do is that no one
should have that kind of power
for once i level the [ __ ] playing
field
i show people
crimson counters
the deep getting back at the seven
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh
god i love it i love it wait love it
wow there's a lot to unpack in that
trailer amazon primed ready for this bad
boy this is this awesome adventure i
love kicking it off with homelander
though after everything you experienced
with stormfront you know it's like
you've seen him constantly searching for
validation and approval in the most
psychotic of ways and now he's really
finding it even more so it was already
leaning this direction but now it's more
apparent than ever it's it's going to be
with like the more the alt-right camp
which seems suiting seems apt knowing
what eric kripke likes to talk about and
knowing the type of character homelander
is voice has always been political go
back to the season one it's always been
a political show if you don't like it
sorry to break it to you i'm excited to
see just how much more crazy he is
because this has been like a slow
escalation to him just having the
ultimate breakdown and this feels like
every season he's just gonna get more
and more unleashed as it progresses i'm
excited for it man what do you think
about our boy soldier boy
boy i cannot wait at all to see what
jensen brings to the season and and
seeing even these brief glimpses here it
seems like he's going to be pretty
important it seems like from at least
the brief synopsis of the season part of
it is going to be about them trying to
find interact with him one of the first
supes you know i just loved the you know
the character that we even are able to
glean out of this trailer like he does
look like somebody who is a more
hardened kind of steve rogers type and i
like that imagery of like him stepping
out of the what looks like the super
soldier serum uh you know chamber and
whatnot and uh what looks like some
incredibly huge
level of power it's like you see him at
first with the shield yeah going all uh
us agent on some guy and then you see
him later on with that big like fire
explosion which i can't imagine would be
his death scene i'm pretty sure that's
his emergency yeah exactly so uh i
cannot wait to see what he brings to
this because he's got the chops for the
drama but you also know that he's going
to be off the leash having fun we know
what he can be like as a gruff you know
authoritative figure but i'm also
excited to see what kind of satirical
and wild uh traits they might bring to
him in this arena where they don't have
as many restrictions as like on the cw
it's funny in the in the comics he's a
little bit more pathetic but he's kind
of more akin a guy who who really looks
to be accepted and it seems like that's
not going to be the portrayal here he's
going to be more of the serious
intimidating type of character i'm
really looking forward to seeing what
his scenes are going to be with anthony
starr specifically because watching
those two pair it up is going to be
awesome yeah we're seeing our boys
getting a chance to use some compound v
for a change you know like they've
teased a lot of what butcher's abilities
are going to be like some super strength
the lasers will frenchy and uh mother's
milk what will their powers and
abilities be and i like that maeve is
actually getting more involved in the
battle as well we're going to be seeing
this other team who's more of a spoof of
like the way how seven is more of a
spoof of justice league we're getting
the team payback which is more of a
spoof of the avengers so in the trailer
you saw the character who kind of looks
like scarlet witch crimson countess i
i'm curious to see what kind of
commentary they'll have on it because
dc's been able to at least do a couple
of r-rated properties so far the boys
comics would often do meta commentary
about comic books boys show has taken
the opportunity to do meta commentary
about comic book movies now they can
take a stab at like the marvel films
where they can go all out that one scene
is i think is going to make a lot of
people be reminded of falcon and winter
soldier which was considered like one of
the most brutal moments in the marvel tv
show pantheon but here you know that
they're gonna go all out and we did get
some teases a little bit of congressman
newman which was how the season left off
with revealing that she was the one
exploding everyone's heads we still
don't know what her ultimate agenda is
they're still keeping her mysterious i
was under the impression that maybe
they'd be leading more with her
considering she was the cliffhanger of
season two however i can't tell if she's
gonna end up working with the boys again
if her ultimate agenda is to take down
the evil supes as well i don't know man
it seems like they're probably gearing
up for some kind of level of satire with
her too because he says that thing about
like i tried to do it the legit way and
it's just not possible i mean you got
like some great little teases throughout
with this trailer obviously homelander
being so heartbroken by stormfront
there's this one scene where it looks
like he's intimidating a train
considering that a train is the one who
gave all the information about
stormfront's nazi background to huey and
starlight i imagine that homelanders
going to find out what a train actually
did and maybe that's what that scene is
implying when he's threatening him you
do see glimpses of
the boy ryan son of a homelander i
didn't know for sure if he'd be back or
not but they've teased him a couple
times now he's going to be getting into
the mix what the vibe i'm sort of
getting from what the boys season three
is going to be dealing with is everyone
reaching like breaking point freaking
the boys have decided to use compound b
the thing they've hit they well some
version of compound b or something of
that nature it's only 24 hours
project power yeah that's what it is
yeah some version of that that allows
them to have some powers which is
something that you know in the previous
seasons you would assume they'd be
opposed to doing anything of that nature
the deep after everything he's gone
through looks like he might even be
getting back into the seven in some way
based or at least that's his goal that
he's constantly striving for even with
soldier boy after awakening in modern
day time his mind has broken everyone
seems like they're on the verge of
breaking point not sure exactly what
they're doing with like giancarlo
esposito and starlight if they're trying
to tease a direction that starlight
might be going down some dark path i
imagine it's just another form of her
doing further infiltration into
uncovering stuff so they can finally
take down bot i think this is gonna be
an awesome possum season i am super
duper stoked for it so be sure to look
out for when our reactions for this show
come up guys if you can subscribe please
do that get accepted into the reject
nation also let's do a p
michael bear michael my boy michael boyd
michael is uh has his own channel omni
media constantly like to shout it out
because he is one of the best out there
currently doing reactions and reviews
wonderful commentary you bet your ass is
going to be covering the boys as well so
if you like reaction channels and you
want to get acquainted with another one
that's freaking great and certainly
deserves more subscribers than us go
subscribe to omni media today because he
is awesome at everything he does ladies
and gentlemen we'll catch you guys soon
[Music]